Neeraj [ __ ] with us on no Sacchi
ana Hallisey and our sake is Akashi what
those characters are speaking isn't
gibberish it's actually a language
called Dothraki and it was invented by
this guy David Peterson in lovely Orange
County California David Peterson is what
we call a con Langer an inventor of
languages con legging is the intentional
creation of a full language creating its
full grammar it's full phonology it's
writing system if it has one and its
entire lexicon david has written many
languages but the first one he wrote was
back in 2000 I was taking an intro
linguistics class at UC Berkeley in 2000
and it was just one day during class I
started scribbling on my notes my very
first language he named it after his
girlfriend named Davi and according to
David himself
it's irredeemably awful it's just not
it's not worth even considering anymore
everything I was doing was his language
was just a kind of really fancy bizarre
way to speak English so I kind of just
started over and said I'll write ground
zero how do I be a language creator
before we move forward let's take a
quick step back and talk about the
Godfather of modern con langing j.r.r
tolkien
you probably know this name because he's
the author of The Hobbit and Lord of the
Rings
he created fourteen different languages
for use within middle-earth Quenya and
Sindarin are probably his most famous he
was the very first person that we know
of to create languages just for fun and
we've been kind of emulating him ever
since now that we've cleared that up
we can move forward we're here in
California because we're curious about
what it takes to create a successful
language David's having two of his
friends who are also con langars come
over and speak with us one of them
brought ice cream we were going to do
this outside but it's too hot so we're
gonna do it inside
the three of them are talking about how
languages are created and they've come
up with five steps take it away guys
oh so alright a naturalistic online
means five basic things one the people
what they do who their neighbors are the
second thing that you're going to need
is a phonology or sound system
do you have voiced and voiceless
consonants do you have aspirated
consonants three words all the nouns all
the verbs all the modifiers fourth
grammar which is the fun part
finally history you know how the
meanings of words changed over time and
you need to know how the grammar of your
language evolved from a time in the
distant past to what's used now now that
we've got that settled let's finish this
in the past 15 years somebody who
created language went from somebody who
was like oh you're a nerd too you know
oh wow that's that's really nerdy which
now means cool and it's prolific use in
television and film proves that it's not
just a passing fancy for television the
difference between a created language
and some other set prop is that the
maximum level of interaction that a
viewer ever has with a background set or
with a prop is just seeing it on-screen
a language on the other hand when you
hear it that's the that's the most real
a language ever gets for that reason you
have to have a fully created language
for a television show and not just a
bunch of gibberish what's that good okay
thank God